Wait,
I
got to keep on flexing and
nobody to thank me.
It's my duty to save the world.
I'll be back in a flash.
My biggest strength is I'm a hard worker and I always give 110 I think it really
stems from my passion and it may be a great boss and you're in your mercy.
I raised weakness.
Well Dad,
I'll express my opinions are tellers.
I disagree with that.
Oh that's a great question.
Well I suppose I called Ross Society Society's first alumni country.
That's a good answer.
Beads.
Okay.
Okay,
well thanks for being with us.
The law school admission board was quite impressed with their application.
This final interview is our last chance to get to know you a little bit better.
So John,
why don't you start by telling us a little bit about yourself.
Sure.
Well I was born and raised right here in the city and I'm the younger of two
brother and ever since I can remember I've wanted it to be a lawyer and I think
it's really,
before we continue,
let me explain how I got here.
That's me.
John Lee.
Yup.
Of the thousands of names and my parents could have given me.
They chose John.
According to the 2010 census,
5% of the US population is Asian American.
It's 15 million people also,
let's assume a 50 50 gender split,
and they say that Lee is the most common,
is at 30% and it feels like one out of every 10 Asian guys.
I is also chunk.
So according to my calculations,
there are another 224,999 other John Lee's rubbing this sir,
I guess you can say that from birth.
I was destined to live a pretty typical Asian late.
For my fifth birthday,
I asked for a baseball Mitt.
Instead,
I received the stethoscope.
I turned nine.
My parents decided they were putting too much pressure on me to become a doctor,
so they let me choose.
They said I can be a lawyer too if I wanted.
When I was 14 my parents gift to me was an sat book.
It was an interesting childhood.
Cities.
By the time I was ready for college,
the birthday present,
stuck coming,
flies.
Oh,
thanks mom.
It's good for you.
Come down for dinner.
No.
Well no,
Tanisha boom,
go.
Uh,
I'm not sure.
Oh,
I'll check later.
Okay.
So,
uh,
you excited to graduate tomorrow and not to college sooner I guess?
Um,
or there'd be more excited.
I was studying film at USC.
USC Bad.
A good film school.
You studied,
prayed hard.
Georgetown.
Much better choice mom.
You know that law is such an unoriginal major.
That's what all the kids say when they can't think of anything else to study.
So that are pre law or premed.
Vison you need,
think about future.
You need respectable career.
How are you gonna you want to study bill making you study as hobby?
Oh,
am I told you it's more than just a hobby for me,
but she'd come in.
None of
that being said that does the movies.
No joking.
This very serious take about computer.
I ain't going to make money from your bank,
but that's how we get old.
You take care of us.
No,
he's so happy.
Happy Studying Pre Med at Columbia Ivy League.
You'd been what I've done and you'll be happy.
I won't say that.
Good.
It had been a big
John Character is important in our profession.
Can you describe someone who has influenced you greatly in your life?
Well,
that's easy.
That'd be my older brother,
Daniel.
You see,
ever since we're young,
he's been there for me and
I love my older brother Danny,
and we couldn't be more different.
Here's a model site.
I love pricing.
The Piano was dedicated to her studies.
I was born to be a dusting.
Let's just say we're pretty different regardless of our differences.
We've always been best friends and he's the only one who's ever supported my
dreams.
You
listen ball tonight.
You sure you want to get schooled again?
Okay.
Oh yeah.
I'll be down in a sec.
Okay.
Hi.
Let's start to get a little bro.
What's up?
See in a diaper.
She's gotten a lot better,
huh?
What's that mean?
Oh,
that's bad,
man.
Hey,
well,
mom said earlier,
don't worry about it.
Georgetown.
Georgetown's a great school.
They got a good billing program,
the girls,
and even better
if they know what you're doing this summer.
Yeah,
I was,
uh,
thinking about during that service trip to Africa that you mentioned,
did you bring a camera with you?
Yeah,
that's a good idea.
Thanks.
Do you ever feel like your life's been mapped out for you already?
Like we're just coloring in the lines.
Yeah.
Mine's kind of like that.
I just wanted to do something more.
There's something,
there's something great,
you know,
does it make sure you're ready to take the opportunities as they come?
Just like basketball.
Take the open shot.
I never miss.
Hey,
I got you something.
I figure it'll come in handy when you get inspired by all those great ideas of
yours.
Thanks Dan.
You don't use it until you get to school.
You can write down all the things you want to tell me.
I'm sure you'll have a lot of great new,
an interesting experiences.
Yeah.
Oh my game.
Best out of three.
You're on.
Okay.
Daniel is right.
I spent four amazing weeks that summer in Kenya,
which sparked a passion for documentary filmmaking and I never expected,
and then it was right about Georgetown too.
They had a great film program and some pretty cute girls.
In fact,
I discovered this in the first day of school,
like most college students class that was often used to catch up on sleep.
Unfortunately,
the class after psych 101 was
good morning everyone
and welcome to your first class in the introduction of the female anatomy.
My name is professor mud
and today we will be discussing
the Fallopian too.
Hmm?
Does anyone know what this is?
Anyone
or the infamous over
once you get me started on the full cycle
to a land that you do not want to go tell us.
Her name is
Sarah.
Yeah,
she's really cool.
You're back couple of days so far I think.
I think you'd like her a lot.
I think I'm going to ask her out tonight.
Oh,
here she comes.
I call you later,
right?
Hi Baby.
This smiling.
Laughing is coming.
Sarah was unlike any girl I've ever met,
was smart,
passionate and beautiful.
She continuously challenged me to become a better person.
It never failed to put a smile on my face.
Ah,
I never intended today the first girl I met at college.
But sometimes love doesn't work out the way we expect.
Just a couple of final questions.
It's hard decisions that make us who we are.
Can you describe a time in your life that you had to make a really difficult
decision?
Robert Frost once said two roads diverged in a wood and I took the one less
traveled by and that has made all the difference.
Now as I prepared to graduate college,
while I'd like to heed Mr. Frost advice,
I seriously doubt that he had Asian parents blocking the path less traveled.
Also,
it doesn't help that Sarah was now literally dragging me down the well beaten
path to attend law school and ultimately to live in middleclass.
Surburbia hey baby.
Hey,
I got you.
It was some thing.
Don't get me wrong.
I love Sarah,
but this is perfect.
How do I look?
It looks well.
I'll definitely wear.
Thank you so much.
[inaudible] Jerry,
what do you got to?
Um,
I was actually just journaling a little bit and uh,
I actually finished that application for the film program I talked to you about
earlier.
I thought you weren't applying to that program.
You know,
I wasn't going to,
but the more I thought about it,
the more I felt like it was just,
you know,
somebody should do,
haven't we talked about this already?
What about going to law school?
You know,
you'd be such a good lawyer.
Look,
I know this means a lot to you,
but what about our plans to live together next year?
I feel like you're just thinking about yourself.
I'm sorry.
Can we talk about slider
got go
that call from my mom mark the worst day of my life.
Daniel was only 23 when he passed away.
My parents convinced everyone that he had died in his sleep,
but the truth was Daniel suffered from depression
and ended up taking his own life.
To this day,
I still don't fully understand why he did it.
We'd been best friends for my entire life,
but I never saw this coming.
I wish I could have known.
I wish I could have had one more minute with them,
just one to convince them not to do it,
but now that he's gone,
I miss him so much.
The rest of my senior year was a bit of a days,
but after Daniel's death I felt like my entire universe was thrown off balance.
I still ended up applying to that film program,
but didn't think too much of it.
Sarah and I never discussed the program or a fight again.
I tried to spend more time with her and she was incredibly supportive and
understanding,
but a couple of weeks after Daniel's death and the day of my final loss of
interview,
I receive some unexpected news,
I guess what I got into that film?
Yeah.
Okay.
I'll call you.
I'll call you after my interview.
Okay,
bye.
Hey John,
I'm not sure when you'll find this note.
I figure you'll find it when the time is right.
Just wanted to say that I know mom and dad can be really tough on you.
Sometimes it's because they worry about you and think they're doing what's best
for you.
You know,
I admire you so much and it's encouraging to see your passion for film,
that kind of passion.
It's something I wish I had more of and is what makes life worth living.
Don't worry.
One day mom and dad will come around to,
I love you bro.
Love Daniel.
John,
what do you want to be a lawyer?
John.
John,
I'm sorry.
What was the question?
I was asking why do you want to be a lawyer?
Ah,
dear Daniel,
you've always been there for me and supported my passion for filmmaking.
Even as kids,
you helped me make my first film and even more that ridiculous superhero
costume.
You'll always be my hero.
Thank you for believing in me and teaching me how to live my life to the fullest
and encouraging me to take the road less traveled.
I know I wouldn't be here without you and for that
I just want to thank you.
Yeah,
man.
I miss you so much as I take this next step in life,
I have no idea what lies ahead,
but thanks to you.
I do know this.
A life with passion is a life worth living
bodily,
right?
Left,
right,
left,
left.